bonjour à merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors ce qui se
passe c'est clair l'obligation vaccinale
de certains salariés au menu par joe
biden est suspendu pour le moment
c'est pas exactement une obligation
vaccinale c'est une obligation de test
mais cela dit effectivement le déteste
ces crises régnant légumes banni de plus
de 100 salariés devraient donner du
temps libre rémunéré aux employés
heureux se faire vacciner et récupérer
les effets secondaires maintenir une
liste des employés vacciner prévenir les
employés testé positif obliger les nous
vacciner à porter un masque tout cela à
leurs frais mais les compagnies ont le
choix entre obliger leurs employés à se
faire vacciner ou
comment dire offrir à leurs employés les
choix que je l'indiqué est donc
évidemment ça serait plus coûteux pour
elle donc on peut supposer que les
entreprises recourent ont
l'obligation vaccinale comme ça quand on
est et constitutionnel
effectivement le il ya une loi qui
permet au congrès le bloquer c'est la
fin de ces deux de suspendre certains
décrets fédéraux pour pour vérification
oh c'est ce que vient de faire une
course fis spatiaux ce n'est pas une
mais ce n'est pas une obligation
maintenant savoir le quant au fond ce
qui va se passer tout cela relève d'un
décret de l'administration sur eux la
santé au travail et cette administration
est légalement autorisés à émettre des
directives en cas de danger grave donc
les cours devront déterminer si le coc
vide est un danger grave est le tenant
parmi tous les bruits de l'instant les
cours devront aussi trancher si des
employés refusent la vaccination pour
des motifs religieux alors cette
suspension appel c'est temporaire
normalement la cour va maintenant
examiner le fond combien de temps ça
peut prendre
à la l'absolu mais pas absolument pas
vous réponse certainement tout sera qui
sera en place va nous avant la fin de
l'année d'une entendu apple pour que le
décret puisse entrer en vigueur ou cas
où ils seraient au cas où ils seraient
acceptés au niveau de la couverture
vaccinale aux états unis on en est où
d'ailleurs on sait que c'était un peu le
cheval de bataille de joe biden oui
alors justement sap la faune et à 58% de
la population qui a une double
vaccination c'est effectivement très
bien parti et en ce moment
ça plafonne les dons coni fait je
suppose que cette ce décret vise à
accélérer la la vaccination sans
recourir ou risque politique purement
politique parce que juridiquement byden
pourrait le faire d'un décret qui
obligerait à vacciner justement on va
parler politique ça revers de taille et
pour joe biden lui qui savourait à peine
ans sa première victoire en je disais en
introduction l'adoption vendredi par le
congrès de son plan pour les
infrastructures alors
vous dire
[Musique]
l'adoption du plan sur les
infrastructures n'est pas vraiment un
succès probable puisqu'elle il est
complètement dissocié de son volet
social le bel bac better qui sera
examiné à la chambre des représentants
25 novembre sans conseils sans qu'on
sache trop comment ce que sera voté a
fortiori ce que sera le sénat quant à l'
oblique quant à comment dire l'art la
contestation
de l'obligation de tests vaccinale je
touche qu'on était les guerres
culturelles sur le vaccin dès le début
rappelle toute la présidence strub
disons qu'elle était prévisible
laurent cesari merci d'avoir été en
direct avec moi je rappelle que vous
êtes professeur d'histoire contemporaine
à l'université d'arras